for sure
uh
the new information technologies are
fragmenting
monolithic
social
consensus
and what i mean by that is for instance
when i was a kid
on friday night
between 6 and 7
[Music]
gunsmoke was on
cbs
you could have fairly high confidence
that 30 percent of the american
population was tuned in
in other words that as a culture we were
all
at the same moment sharing this
experience
now you know
people follow their own interests and so
there is enormous fragmentation and this
thing i call the balkanization of
epistemology goes along with that now we
aren't either catholics lutherans or
jews
now there's a vast
smorgasbord of possibilities even the uh
you know and it continues to fragment
almost down to the individual level
so for instance
i used to be a news hound
once that meant
hourly
newscasts
now whenever i need to know what's going
on in the world whether that's twice a
day or twice an hour i just go to the
top stories page at yahoo and and it's
delivered to me so there is a tendency
for us to excentrify
and and island ourselves but in a way
that is is the precondition for uh
creativity that what we give back to the
society based on our
personal ex
pursuit of our own eccentric agendas
what we give back to the society then
are diverse insights
new understandings that can't arise in
an environment
of consensus
as to then
what your question implies the the the
counter flow of that how shall we build
than
uh
a culture
in a way i think that what we're seeing
is the end of culture
that culture
is a
xenophobic
paranoid notion
our culture means our consensus how we
think how we do things the foods we eat
at the end of culture at the end of that
road at the dissolution of culture what
you have is enormous
diversity
one other next week i'll be spending a
few days in manhattan
one of the reasons i love that town so
much
is because you never know
what's next and you never know who's
next and through the genius of its
verticality
the rich cannot escape the culture of
the streets and the streets are not free
from having the very wealthy the very
rich
move among them i mean
so everybody is confronted with
everybody else and it's being confronted
by people you never imagined you would
be confronted with
that teaches you tolerance
you know if you if you've never had to
deal with people of a different
ethnicity or class or gender preference
well then you're just free to have any
kind of paranoid fantasies you want
about how those people operate but if
you are constantly in the presence of
diversity you begin to become
sophisticated this is what civilized
means it means you know your jaw doesn't
drop when somebody walks by
with a hairstyle or a fashion or a
manner unfamiliar to you you make
a place for that
and it's xenophobia that drives warfare
territoriality search for ideological
purity pogroms inquisitions
so forth and so on so uh and it's very
psychedelic to tolerate
this diversity and what psychedelics
teach you i think is that underneath all
these expressions of diversity there's
another human soul
a human animal and there there is great
homogeneity
uh
one of the
concepts that's probably going to take a
real pounding as we move into the future
is the preciousness of the individual
personality the preciousness of the
individual ego i can imagine a future
where
bodies are nodal points in a web and you
just settle where it's comfortable for a
while and then move on and make room for
someone else
and you don't have to own a body and you
don't have to
you know have one personality one body
you can become context dependent and as
avatars
flourish and this sort of thing you all
know what i mean by avatars i mean
these
software constructs that are how you
appear to other people on the internet
you know and these will be your
personalities well eventually we'll all
have 50 or 60 avatars hanging in our
virtual closet
and you'll get up in the morning and
decide you know
do i want to be a meteorite the queen of
england
a german pop star
or
whatever and mood will
and diversity will rule it's all about
boundary dissolution plasticity
transformation and the replacing of
solid and defined entities with more
amorphous and self-transforming
entities
perhaps we will become self-transforming
machine learners at least in some of our
avatars
[Music]
you